margot robbie and her supporting cast of
strong independent women flocked the box
office february 6th for the opening
night of birds of prey while reviews
have largely been positive we've got it
on good authority a certain Leto Jared
hasn't taken too kindly to the whole
leaving him out of the movie thing
in fact he's gone on the record multiple
times to air his grievances with the
intentional exclusion of his audacious
Joker performance why exactly is Jared
Leto not making a cameo in the latest
Harley Quinn film let's just say we have
our theories and Jared Leto has his stay
tuned for some hilarious dialogue from
our favorite pigtailed antihero as well
as some seriously awesome fight scenes
the choreography set design and costume
design for this film is off the charts
with many hidden homages to the comic
book characters themselves and other
eclectic pop-culture Easter eggs and
let's keep this to awesome oh wait
before we go any further we just want to
let you know that this video does
contain some minor spoilers for the
birds of prey films so of course proceed
with caution
so without further ado let's take a trip
to the recent past to figure out why
birds the word at the box office it all
harkens back to Suicide Squad who can
forget Jared Leto's performance in
Suicide Squad
it was campy unhinged and a little on
the nose while his exuberant performance
was certainly cartoonish the fans were
anything but nostalgic for his comic
inspired character and his take on the
Joker turned out to be one of the most
controversial cinematic performances of
the decade and even if you enjoyed his
performance in Suicide Squad it's
impossible to ignore his offstage antics
that took place during the filming of
the movie
in fact many film viewers have said
their knowledge of Jared Leto's behavior
during the production of Suicide Squad
actually negatively impacted their film
viewing experience and while his
behavior has been very well documented
we'll give a refresher for those of you
who are out of the loop as this
information is paramount to let his
exclusion in birds of prey among the
many grotesque things Jared Leto did
during the Suicide Squad production some
of the grossest included scenting margot
robbie alive rat and a pig carcass
filled with bullets during the table
read it's no wonder Jared Leto wouldn't
exactly be Margot Robbie's top pick for
a co-star given the pair's per
professional history when you're acting
Joker like how do you see any Jared not
for a second it was it was joka and he's
he's nuts sources have said jared leto
also sent used condoms to his co-stars
throughout the production when
questioned about his lewd behavior Leto
defended himself saying at least they
were used to everybody I did a lot of
things to create a dynamic to create an
element of surprise a spontaneity and a
reality to break down any kind of walls
that may be there the Joker is somebody
who doesn't really respect things like
personal space or boundaries method
acting isn't anything new many actors
including Heath Ledger have taken on
bizarre behaviors to get fully immersed
into the role of the Joker but the good
people at Warner Brothers weren't too
keen on having Leto back on in fact they
gave the newest Joker film to Todd
Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix which led
it was pretty upset about he even tried
to get the film cancelled when it was
still in pre-production even in Suicide
Squad let it only got about 10 minutes
of screen time in the final cut of the
film even though he was billed as the
main character this is due to the film's
director not being too thrilled with
letõs overall performance I did a lot of
work in the film and a lot was oh there
were so many scenes that got cut from
the movie I couldn't even start now that
Todd Phillips Joker has taken the world
by storm
any chance of Leto having his own Joker
film are pretty much over one source
told The Hollywood Reporter how does
Leto play the Joker he established
following Phoenix it kind of ends his
Joker run talk about a tough act to
follow you can change your game
my son Dave birds-of-prey features a
Harley Quinn who has recently cut ties
with Jared Leto's version of the Joker
in an interview with heroic Hollywood
birds-of-prey director Kathy Ann was
asked why Leto wouldn't be returning to
the silver screen to accompany his
fantabulous female companion Harley
Quinn Kathy said well for us I think the
movie starts with the break-up and then
it's all about Harley and we just wanted
to work with that and whatever we needed
him to be just to show that he existed
and that there was a breakup but the
focus of the movie is definitely not on
the Joker this sentiment is consistent
throughout Kathy's film as even though
the Joker has mentioned several times
throughout the movie he is never
explicitly shown in fact any mention of
the Joker is purely used as context for
Harley's character so even if Jared Leto
had been in birds of prey the closest he
could have come to a cameo was a shot of
the Joker's arm and backside in the
tattoo torture flashback wonder how much
money he would have expected to be paid
for those shots considering he made
seven million dollars in Suicide Squad
in the tattooing flashback Harley Quinn
and the Joker are torturing a man by
tattooing a clown mask on to his face
and black ink the scene is brutal but
brief and is the only time in the film
any part of the Joker is shown on screen
and anyway with such a strong cast who
needs Leto Mary Elizabeth Winstead
jurnee smollett Belle and Rosie Perez
all did a fantastic job on the film
providing more than enough competent
acting chops to take this film to the
next level and they did it without
sending their cast members dead rats
used condoms or pig carcasses at that
birds-of-prey is loaded with phenomenal
acting performances from the female
ensemble with many epic fighting scenes
and a brilliant soundtrack to boot it
just goes to show you don't necessarily
need to method act to give an
outstanding performance give this video
a like if you can't wait to see what the
film has in store for viewers everywhere
I thought okay everyone's gonna want to
see Harley in the Joker but what I
really want to see is a girl gang film
and I don't really get to see action
films with a female ensemble ever said
Margot Robbie in a recent interview by
BBC Radio 4 birds of prey in this
interview Margot was asked a series of
thoughtful questions about the film
she met with equally interesting answers
she was asked what makes Harley so
special by the BBC interviewer why is
she important to so many people
Margot gave several compelling answers
including she's in love with a madman
while the Joker is an undeniably
important part of her character
development
Margot also said people's love of the
character came from her unflappable
sense of humor and the fact that she
isn't perfect and she's making a lot of
mistakes further in the interview she
explains her involvement in pitching the
idea for Harley Quinn sequel
I literally pitched this right after
going to comic-con we were halfway
through shooting Suicide Squad the movie
wasn't even finished filming and
everyone there was dressed as Harley and
I was like whoa I think there's gonna be
a bit of heat around this character and
if there's this kind of response then
the studio might want me to play her
again and if that's the case then I'd
like it to kind of be on my terms I
don't want the character to be put in a
situation that doesn't really behoove
her Robbie could have been referring to
the chaos of Suicide Squad and how she
wanted to have more control over how she
and Harley were portrayed in future
films
smart move Robbie we think it's really
gonna pay off over clowns so what did
your letter have to say about the
premiere of birds of prey we headed to
Instagram to get his hot take on the
subject though he'd been quite vocal
about his mistreatment and
misrepresentation on Suicide Squad Leto
exhibited great restrain and brevity
with his reaction to the announcement of
the birds of prey film in 2019 here is
the reaction in question a simple
Instagram story no words no images just
a clown emoji on a black background upon
first glance this image can come off as
cute quaint or at most a bit petty the
clown emoji is no doubt referring to the
Joker who obviously isn't the main
subject of birds of prey by any stretch
It was as if Leto was saying to his 10
million Instagram followers hey don't
forget about me but upon closer
inspection we see what's written in
between the lines or in this case in
between the emojis in this profound
Instagram post Leto validated what
critics had said all along about his
performance but his Joker days are
deservedly over here sits the face of a
clown and it could really be any clown
in the middle of a vast 2-dimensional
nothingness this void is similar to the
one in which Suicide Squad resides
with no further plans to cinematically
evolve the characters in that timeline
the film has been sentenced to an
eternity in the catacombs of box office
flop purgatory while Harley Quinn may
have flown the nest into commercial
success with birds of prey the host of
her former cameo becomes lost to the
sands of time we now turn our gaze
toward the emoji the clown is
represented only by its head
perhaps referencing the immense amount
of ego involved in letõs performance and
the simplistic surface-level
interpretation he presented to worldwide
audiences in 2016 it is small it is
unblinking and simple it will never
learn or grow it will stay forever in
the corner of the world Jared Leto has
carved for himself a place in which
mediocre talent is forever embalmed in
self-obsession hey maybe that's the
secret to it's ageless look the guy's 48
for goodness sake and he still looks
like the brooding heartthrob Jordan
Catalano from my so-called life sorry
Jared Leto we really don't want to tease
you too much we're just having a little
fun
so while Jared Leto has been pretty
low-key on birds of prey so far we can
be sure to expect something from the
charismatic drama King and of course
we'll keep you updated on whatever he
has to say and now we want to hear from
you are you totally excited to see this
film now that it's in theaters and which
version of the Joker is your favorite
let us know in the comments we'd love to
hear from you and don't forget to
subscribe to this channel to keep up to
date on all our latest content
I'm up
[Music]